hey guys I have been asked a few times
to do a Wimpy Joe please
so that means I have to do more scary
games and honestly I've tried quite a
few and they're not scaring me and I
remembered a game I play with my friend
a while ago that loud suit is kept that
she told me is that she just on my game
it's off with a link in the description
I'm already here in the music and is
already kind of freaking me out I'm a
sucker for jump scares the legend has it
there's a health and a small town that
has been closed and left empty for
decades the house belonged to a wealthy
family I commit suicide from that time
the neighbors have closed the house
forget as it leaves at the house where
all the family committed suicide his
curse some said that they have heard a
woman screaming from the house yet so no
one dare to enter the house are you
apparently so yeah
like that
I'm inside that's the first step okay
the aim of the game is to click things
this way pointless I can feel something
strange this house
I actually feel it this Oh since the
first time I came to work here I'm so
afraid of that and see if I can jump in
right now okay fine that's fine I can do
with you deal with you
see the odd thing is I do into abandoned
houses quite a lot I never see any of
this [ __ ] quite a lot I'm totally lying
I don't eat under the bed there's no
better than swim so I'm fine nothing is
happening
fine just again is there anything else
oh yes did it this was the worst
I'll move the bathroom being [ __ ]
terrifying because bathrooms just aren't
right finals week everything scary come
on
stop it stop it
you feel relaxed
oh [ __ ]
ah be there for the anti anything
I've done two on kit
I forgive you okay the funny thing is
now I need to go torta I'll be right
back
that's from the toilet and I did not die
let's carry on with the bedroom kids
yeah creepy right
God make kids at bloody creepy music
how many Bovary us that's not attractive
is there in lights which cannot see oh
okay we all know what is on the end of
this rope don't we oh yes we do yes
path has been foiled but okay no no let
me turn back on get good that's always
handle a [ __ ] am I supposed to do
ah woman why do you think you for
talking about under the bed
I don't even know what the first I don't
wait time allows I don't want to tell
about my grave
I can't look under the bed I don't know
what you're trying to say to me okay
okay fine safer save that sounds safe
nice to see some peace before Joe it's
nice
am I supposed to know a code that's not
got a key how am I supposed to know did
I mean it somewhere else am i being
forgetful
they have to go back and find out then
support seven [ __ ] yeah why I'm moving
in here I mean II need to tell you does
happen
yeah there isn't in any money why I have
to die I want to live no matter what
oh please now do you have to what oh
[ __ ] off no way I don't want to click
anywhere please why I was such a pansy I
just finished it it's at the end can I
go now please please do something guys
like Toy Story
hello now I have to take actually okay
that wasn't so bad
I don't think I wanna go I hope at least
some of you got entertainment for my
scares because I didn't exactly well I'm
dying I did enjoy that but it's
terrified I'm such a [ __ ] I know that
probably already was scaring me anyway
if you have any ideas for any other
scary games you want me to play if you
want me to carry on doing this then let
me know a nice evening or day whatever
bye